>>> SHE S DE
ADVAAGE . PLSR YA
REPUBLICAN NDIDATE DONARU
PRESIDD SHE
WON.D SEOR C
IN PRESIDENT TRUMP'S WHI
Y NOTA
RYC OPPONEN HER HUSBAN TERM, II
CONSIDSSISTANT
GENERAL BEGAN TVINST
THEN EMPLOYERHACONTICONTINUE TS
WAS ISNLY
WHAT WAS THE DEAL?
WELLITTEN W
APTLY HERE ITHE .
KENNNOW. YOUBO BEFOR ASSOP,  MI,
THE JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE HAWII
JANUARY 6t DU BLAMHA
>> I CERTAINLY BLAME THE
I S  PRESIDENT TL LAWSPLLD
BE AE
INVESTIPPENED.
I'AL WHAT .FROM TE N JANUARY 6tW
DONAMP AND MIKE PENCMPLISHED TO
SPEAKIJUST HAVE A MINOFACTUAL
ON FOR HAVINMI
SHINLE A ARYOAGE ANCHOR AND
FLATTERING THE ANCHOD BEIN
INVITED BACK.
THLY GET
REPUBLICAN ON THESE DAYS ITHEY'.
SO --
>> NO, NO NO.
LISTEN TO ME.
LISTEN, I INVITEY OFS FOR WHATE
DO.TOTHE TE VE
I  YES. DOTWEET. YEEN HAED
SPICER CAME TO ME AND SAID
FI D H
HIS NAME OCONSIDERATIO HE HAACC
THE CIVIL DIVISION OF THE ST
GEOF
WAS ALREINTERVIEWING STAFF
FO I
TR
SAIDO BUT.YOU KNOWIN 2016, KNOWE
O ALLEGIANCE TA CAL PA PRESIL
FEEOKEN BSEI ALRI
UN S'SBUGEAEHAT PEOPLEHOWAY,DON
WITH NOT INSS WI
TO TAKE THAT CAMPAIGN MANAGEMENT
JOB AND HELPING  MORE D HO, I D.
>> THE BOOK IS PAGESAT'S MISSIN
>> I LIK TAL
ICOME TO G OUHAT EVER
DITHE HELL ARE YOU DNG HERAT
WA DIET  TRUMP, TRUMP, TRUMP.
I WI TYOU THAT I KNOW HE
THE YEAR Y "THE IMES."AS MENTIO4
QUOTE,
EV HIM AHO
HERO NOT AT ME SOME KIND
AL
CAEDCT WAS ING TO EXIST, ERE
DUMPING AN OP-
HI TO BE ABOUTOS
AGSAYING WHY DIDR ONFF
ALTHOUGH THEY DIDN'T OR RETHEY T
GEORGE -I S OWED
T A  I
GO BE A PUBLIC SERVANT
D TO HAVG JOB
A MILY.NISTRN.WE MOVED O FAMILY
ALL TOGETHER.
HE CHANGEDIS MIND OULDALON DONAL
CHANGES.
I ALSON'D.
RED WHEN THEY WERE
ATTACKING ERI Y LI. LYNEOM THE L
MY TO BE,
YOGU
AND BY T WAY, OU'R
OKAY.
T.WAY ERE'S A FINALITY TO WHATTH
AORDINRIES.
OUGH TO MARRIAGE
YOUR SUPPORT OF MY CAREE
ALLOWEME AND
MY SHOT I16O KEO
WASHIN,
AM I MISREADING
IF I HADN'T READ W
MUS OHET I KINDF READ I A
ESPONSE.
>> WL, IT'S GRATITLOVINGLYEOEATE
MARRIAGE, THE FOURLDWE MAREDI H,
EARLY 40UIOU
ING TO D
INS SEGMENT IN THE OM HEARING A
UMP, TRUMP,
AND I THINK GEORGEE
THINGS PEOPLE
AREALLY WANTED S NDASYSAD
GE
LAW
.
T.
MIRE>> I DON'TUT
I WANTED TTION.OW. YI HOPE YOU'
>> THERE'S BEEN H
>>
KELLY ANNEY F  A GWAY.E .S IT T
FACEBOOKO WE
YOU SHOULD BE ASHAME
UROH, GIVE MAN'I
E .
T HERE T
OFF THSCT THE CAMERASE.N.I DON'
INVITATIONS TO SID
.'S NEVHE THAT ROLLED.
E THY TO
IS BOOK, WHICH IS ON
OF THE HOTTEST ITHTR
WITH THE AUTHO ASK